[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video I'm bringing
three headed ring on theory as well as
who the Turing Rider might be but before
I get right into it let's first take a
look on some facts regarding the dragon
riding western riding such a big deal
way back in the day the Targaryens
learned how to master and ride dragons
as beasts of war allegedly by using a
combination of practice and sorcery
dragon riding just like forging Valyrian
steel is considered the lost art and
extremely effective method of warfare
Targaryen riders served one so first
United the Seven Kingdoms can anyone
ride a dragon first of dragons can never
be fully tamed and could even be
dangerous for their own rider in the
books a character named Quentyn Martell
tried to follow Danny's lead and take
the control of one of her other dragons
bazarian but that torch by the third
dragon regal this Martell was written
out of the show but fans were very
worried that Tyrion might meet the same
fate when he approached these two
luckily enough Tyrion survived next time
I have an idea like that punch me in the
face
then his invasion of Westeros
particularly the Battle of the gold road
left fans wondering if it would made
more sense for her to bring all three
dragons to battle instead of only one
the answer lies in fact that then is
only able to entirely control jørgen and
therefore does not want to put her own
army at risk using all three dragons she
did handle her other two dragons pretty
capably in the battle marine and in the
battle beyond the wall however in both
of these situations her armies did not
participate it was only her dragons
against the enemy armies thus Daenerys
was able to bring all three and just
burn everything on sight
however when den is marching her arms as
well she does not raise bringing other
two as they don't have the riders and
cannot be fully controlled but is being
said let's now take a look on Dana's
outfits which is also for huge
importance for the three hydrogen theory
as I believe that her season 7 outfits
are for sharing that this is coming true
thence outfits rather serious used to
mostly be a blue color this is because
Khal Drogo's khalasar used the color
blue to identify themselves from magical
stars they never blew a lot to remember
him this fact is important for you to
understand that Game of Thrones outfits
usually symbolize room for shed of
something throughout the last season
Danny more outfits that contain dragon
motifs and matches with colors over
house which is pretty common among the
lords and ladies every Lord king or
queen wears an outfit that contains a
symbol of his or her social mean
there's nothing surprising the Danvers
scholars and motives on her dresses that
matches with her own house
as you can see Danny often bears the
three-headed dragon pet which a first
does not hint not much to confirm any
theory but on the other hand the same
pain that seems just every other regular
pain my thing that the popular tree had
a general theory might come true in the
final season before I continue let me
just highlight this unlike most other TV
shows Game of Thrones the show that has
many times foreshadowed main events far
in advance that's mostly because
showrunners David Benioff and Dan Weiss
have a show based on a book series and
show is not written on season by season
basis let me just put it this way by the
time they started writing the first
episode of the very first season they'd
already known about all main events and
deaths that will happen in the upcoming
season so they had decided foreshadow
most of them which is on a plane reasons
this show is one of if not the best TV
show ever produced let me give you a few
examples Ned Stark's death was
foreshadowed in the very first episode
of the series as we all know Ned Stark
accompanied in with John Robb Theon
brain and a few other men came upon a
daredevil a few months later we found
out that this dire wolf was killed by a
stag which actually foreshadowed Robert
Baratheon a stag getting Ned the wolf
killed by inviting him to King's Landing
while six paps never left behind upon
the dials that represented six children
then he also had a little finger for
sharing time and when Esther's death
wasn't safe for her inside people died
matter dinner tables they die in their
beds they die squatting over their
chamber pots
everybody dies sooner or later you don't
worry about your death worry about your
life
take charge of your life for as long as
it lasts that is what it means to be
lord in the eighth episode of the fourth
season Littlefinger had a conversation
with Robin who was afraid of leaving
home following his mother's death Robin
thinks it's safer for him to stay inside
but Littlefinger comforted him by saying
that people can die anywhere
Littlefinger said people died there
dinner tables people died near death's
they die squatting over their chamber
pots and a few episodes later she was
killed on her bed and Tywin Lannister
was killed while squatting over his
chamber pots these are just a couple of
examples of Game of Thrones
foreshadowings just to point out that
every small talk every small item that
Fiat moments sometimes don't even catch
might be for sharing something huge it
is being said any spin might still be
nothing more than a regular pin but
taking into consideration all previous
scenes that foreshadow major events
that's a much more distant first sight
regular pin might have much bigger
importance might be a clue that the
three-headed ring of fear will come true
so as I've been saying this three-headed
dragon pinned beside being a regular pin
that represents Targaryen sigil might
also foreshadow that beside Danny in the
night king riding dragons there might be
one more dragon rider that will ride the
one remaining dragon Rago let me
introduce the theory that this
three-headed dragon pin might be
foreshadowing
so basically going to this theory
rhaegar targaryen statement in Danny's
vision the Dragons three heads means
that each of Danny's three dragons will
have their own riders for all the way
that are not caught up with the books
are probably wondering when the Traeger
say this I'll try to explain to you then
he saw visions in the house of the
undying in both in the books and on the
show but her visions are quite different
in the books Dan is so no vision of Joe
and her son but she did see many
revisions so which one was a vision of
her brother Rhaegar saying the dragon
has three heads the first dragon rider
is obvious then he has an unbreakable
bond and connection with dragon who is
named after her late husband called Joe
going is the largest one after the
heartbreaking battle beyond the wall the
night King Rises Aryan and Dany only has
two dragons left since she rides shotgun
it would only fit for John - one less
living Targaryen - right Ragle into the
battle at some point probably after he
learns of his show parentage a year ago
I already made a video regarding this
the three hydrogen theory that already
rule to be quite accurate in that videos
explain how the three hydrogen theory
has been foreshadowed as well as which
characters might make up the
three-headed dragon prophecy
long story short who those three dragon
riders
maybe Danny obviously has an unbreakable
bond with Rogen and John snow being the
last Targaryen beside Danny would write
a dragon named after his father Rhaegar
but not before the last season regarding
the 3rd dragon rider that is required to
fulfill the three-headed dragon theory I
said that it would be nice to see Danny
John interior riding the Dragons into
battle against the night king but I also
said that it was kind of too obvious and
simple to be true this would have also
fulfil Tyrion story of how he wanted the
dragon for his name day only to be
disappointed by loud laughter from his
family some claim tearless ruled rides
Aryans since he already managed to earn
their trust and unshackled m2n claiming
that dragons are intelligent much more
than most people will quickly recognize
friend from foe in my opinion is the
best explanation and the only reason
dragons did not kill Tyrion about the
Dragons we have to choose them here
beneath the pyramid they are not eating
they haven't touched any food since
Queen Daenerys left Daenerys is the
dragon queen I can't very well let the
Dragons starve that's obvious the dragon
does not want to eat how do you force
him to eat dragons do not do well in
captivity how do you know this that's
what I do
I drink and I know things the dragons
Aegon used to conquer Westeros ranged
over hundreds of miles
then Daenerys his ancestors started
chaining them up in pens few generations
later and lost dragons no larger than
cats
they must be Unchained or their waste
away Sunday how many times were you in
the company of these dragons many times
and did they ever harm you never dragons
are intelligent more intelligent than
men according to some masters they have
affection for their friends and fury for
the enemies
dragons realized that he's a friend and
not an enemy meaning that even though
Tyrion did manage turned her trust he
most likely will not be the one to ride
the turret dragon instead I stated that
the net king will be the third Dragon
Rider and therefore we would have Danny
fired 19 guys and just snow ice and fire
riding three dragons the first part of
my theory already came true in the
season 7 finale living the last part of
it yet to come true
John snowriding Rago after the season
six finale in huge revelation of Jon
Snow's true parentage John isn't a
bastard but rather a son of Leon stark
and rhaegar targaryen also known as the
Last Dragon it's pretty easy to assume
that John is the second rider Jon Snow
will most likely write ragout the dragon
named after his father beside they need
night King and John Snow there's one
more person that will most likely ride
the dragon well not technically ride but
skin change in the dragon and I'd have
to guess barrel skin change into
bazarian the night king is dragon I've
been watching you all of you all of your
lives with a thousand eyes and one now
you've come to me at last Brandon Stark
though the hour is late I didn't want
anyone to die for me he died so you
could find what you have lost
going to help me walk again you'll never
walk again
but you will fly for so long fans have
been wondering why would bran need to
skin change into one of Danish dragons
since season seven gave us the answer
it's because all three dragons are not
fighting for the same sight anymore and
therefore controlling tonight Kings and
the dragon will build the crucial
importance in the great four to come
skin changing the dragon is most likely
possible for the strongest warg
skin-changer to ever live Brent had
worked in two horrors so many times and
yet skin change neither human is very
harder than working into an animal and
yet brain already mastered that skill
long ago before meeting the three-eyed
Raven just as three-eyed Raven said bran
will never walk again but he will fly in
conclusion the final season will
certainly see all three dragons having
their own writers and one might even be
controlled by brain and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]